[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of one of my favorite humans and
favorite comedians Tom Papa who has a
new Netflix special coming out on
December 13th it's called what a day
what a day Tom Papa colon what a day
check it out and check out everything
Tom has ever done including you're doing
great his other special on Netflix he's
just one of the best around and this
isn't like a getting to know Tom this uh
episode this is like a hang he and I
hung and hung and it went to like a
really interesting conversation about
the ego that I was not expecting that he
was not expecting and it was it really
stood stuck it stuck with me and I
really hope you guys like it uh I'm
excited for you to hear it if you want
to see me live before we get to it if
you let well if you like stand-up comedy
come see me I'm going to be in San
Francisco Portland Seattle Atlanta
Charlotte and Washington DC tickets to
all of those will be are are currently
at petehomes.com and if you like the
podcast it's the season to give a weirdo
a gift of a Pete's pick or give yourself
a pizza pick these are actually products
that I actually use and actually love
like the perfect Jean which is exactly
what it's called the perfect Jean I've
been looking for these pants my entire
life I literally own five pairs of the
perfect jeans in five different colors
and I just rotate I wear them year round
I wear them to Casual things I've worn
them to fancy premieres with a jacket
and jeans that look with nice sneakers
they look fantastic they look like
designer jeans but they're only 60 bucks
with the promo code which is awesome and
they don't feel like designer jeans
designer jeans feel terrible there's no
give there's no give there's no Bend
these are two percent Ray um two percent
two percent spandex two point five
percent rayon there I got it out and
they provide extra comfort and movement
that your man's Parts require that means
these gen these jeans stretch so your
nuts ain't Crush thereby providing the
only true home for your bone I've bought
so many of these and there's no looking
back and here's my favorite part
they last they are made with the best
sewing techniques and premium highest
quality materials to provide you maximum
durability so not only are they
incredibly soft but they last an
incredibly long time I hate replacing
jeans and I haven't had to replace my
perfect jeans yet it's so wonderful to
know it's one and done buy them in every
cut buy them in every color now you're
going to look great no you're going to
feel great best of all they're not
khakis [__] your khakis and spare your
nuts the perfect Gene for the Perfectly
Imperfect man just 60 bucks when you use
code weirdo at checkout and show your
support of the show liberate your lower
limbs with the one and only perfect Jean
whether you're working with lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover or a bagel
and eggplant the perfect Gene has got
you covered take a peek at
www.theperfect Gene that's with the J
the perfect j-e-a-n dot NYC and use code
weirdo for 25 off at checkout that's the
perfect Gene dot N1 I see code weirdo
for 25 off at checkout this episode is
also brought To Us by our friends at on
it maker of my favorite new atropic
Alpha Brain Alpha Brain has absolutely
changed my life
it's changed my relationship to work
focus and creativity it is a new atropic
it's like a it's like fish food for your
brain it is not a stimulant it's not
like caffeine or an energy drink it is
just simply Earth grown ingredients that
have been perfectly dialed in to help
you maximize your focus your
concentration and for me my creativity
for the past almost 10 years now I
haven't done a podcast I haven't written
a script I haven't done stand up I
haven't even gone on a date or sat down
to answer a bunch of emails without
taking two or three Alpha Brain about 15
minutes before I need to be dialed in
and get into that zone you absolutely
feel the difference it is a dialed in
wonderful feeling that your brain has
everything it needs to to function at
its highest level so if you do something
that involves your brain and chances are
you do why not give yourself that
Advantage I keep it in my car in my
carry-on for travel I keep it in my
office it's in the pockets of my jackets
I even just started trying Alpha Brain
Black Label which is impossibly even
better I I love it it's changed my life
and the best way to know if you like it
is to try it Go to onit.com
onnit.com weird you'll get 10 off
everything you see on that Landing Page
Plus show your support of the show
that's on it.com slash weird get into it
and get your noodle cooking with gas
never said that before last but not
least do you like podcasts sure you do
maybe even thinking about even starting
a podcast or maybe recording a music
album that's what people call the music
albums or maybe you want to do some
voiceover for that cartoon you want to
upload to Youtube I don't know but
chances are you want high quality Studio
sound without paying high ass Studio
prices well luckily our friends at Blue
microphones have got you covered I'm
currently speaking into a blue
microphone that's why I sound so
fantastic this is a blue Sona XLR mic
for podcasters it is incredible and even
before we have these guides for years we
were recording this podcast on their
most famous mic the Blue Yeti which is
the simplest USB mic you can find that
sounds incredible and is incredibly easy
to use even if you're new to recording
it's also the only USB mic that I found
that has different settings for solo
meaning the mic points just at you
sitting across from somebody meaning it
points at both directions or
omnidirectional where it records
everything in the room so cool that you
can have those different settings so if
you're doing it solo like Bill Burr an
interview like this podcast or just
trying to record an entire sound
experience the mic has got you covered
they are made by the same company that
make that make high-end Studio mics that
have been used on a lot of big records
blue has been around for more than 20
years so you know you can trust them and
today blue is part of Logitech for
creators so show your support of this
podcast and get your auditory dreams
rolling by going to bluemike.com and use
promo code weird for a special deal on
any blue microphone that's bluemike.com
bluemic.com and use promo code weird for
a special deal on any Blue mic and show
your support of the show alright guys be
sure to check out Tommy pops on December
13th I'd hope to see you on the road in
the meantime enjoy this chat get into it
just cross your legs and get on the get
on the [__] couch really you don't
have to everybody does what you do
go ahead
be the little boy
oh boy
you don't have to I can
you can choose on on the couch no look
at this couch this is my single guy
couch oh it's filled with come I've
[__] all every every inch of this cup
of this cup it actually is coming you
know how like old people
there's the ref I went to the plastic
covered Furniture you went right to the
gym
this is a black couch
well thanks for opening with jizz
um and we are recording I didn't open
with just you did that's true
but but this is my uh this is a filthy
couch is all I was trying to say it's
not it's not actually filthy and it's
not actually covered in the J word I
have a chair in my living room that was
from my apartment in New York and it is
like and we just said last night that
it's really like
it's not a good chair we all love the
chair who's uh who's my wife and I yeah
we're like we love the chair love the
jam but it's not a good chance it's your
college room chair that you just love
and it's it's probably got levels of
dirt you can't even see but it's but
it's should I are we allowed to keep
that as adults in our living room I'm
saying make it into your podcast set
yeah you're almost zero effort podcast
said I'm it's a great podcast I need a
new podcast set for make baking bread
with Tom Papa yeah because uh
yeah the angle's not good it's not
flattering you mean it's not flattering
for you my whole existence is just
please somebody look how high these
babies are yeah just don't catch me this
angle don't you don't want the travel
neck pillow of Flesh yeah exactly my my
own podcast yeah you're right that's
what I used to say you have the pillow
right there on the Pete home show I was
like please raise the camera so so much
of my life is like I am not the same
size as you like I am so much taller
than whoever the standard was or whoever
you did the lighting right triple it
yeah triple it and that's what Val and I
Val and I are always eating the same
size meal
[Music]
I am not the same size yeah I'm a giant
I'm a giant help me out and I did I
recorded my podcast in New York in uh
the comedy seller podcast studio and I
looked great it was like shot in this
nice angle and I was like oh I'd be so
much more popular if people thought this
was who I was
if I told them this lie instead of the
other right exactly this is a better lie
it's a much better lie so I'm thinking
of get of trying to get a space for the
new year maybe hey maybe we could do it
together because Katiana were just
saying it's like maybe it's time for
like a proper yeah space and if you have
it be like a swing set you can have
different shows yeah oh that could be
smell like me and I'm like a little
closer to where you go where you come
from yes so it would probably cut your
commute down oh that brunch yeah okay
where would that be where's the middle
ground there I I don't like to say on
the radio it rhymes with Merman moeks
around that area
can I say something we could even do
Woodland Mills yeah you
can see Woodland milk that would cut
your commute from MOHAI from MO
nobody cares uh what's his name there's
a guy John he's The Punisher
barenthal he lives in Ohio I can say
that with confidence because I was like
oh maybe he because I see him about I'm
like oh maybe it's Hush Hush yeah cover
of Ojai magazine this month
at home and oh hi it's just here I am
no one cares nobody cares no what are
you gonna do and yeah but I would be up
for it if you can if you can just
promise me a less fat angle I can do it
I would I'd be into it LFA yeah less fat
less fat not still fat still fat you
want to be relatably fat yeah I know not
too buff either yeah if you're super
buff
yeah I'm not sure about that well
buffton Papa doesn't work but no Bob
Chappelle better
yeah weirdly weirdly didn't think that
was gonna work think about Killing Them
Softly yeah skinniest boy did not think
that was gonna work the youngest
smallest skinniest young man Dave
Chappelle bone arms killing it I'd say
loudly actually not even softly it's
kind of sets you up for a great
compliment that his ideas are bigger
than whatever package it's in like his
ideas were it didn't matter I also
should note I know there's some Scandal
happening right now I don't really
follow
really follow scandals so I know that
there's a Chappelle a new one well the
SNL one yeah I read about that right so
a couple weeks old so it's over it's
over we don't care anymore no
the river of [__] has moved in along now
somebody that didn't really stick news
site it didn't stick no not really all
all I'm just being selfish I'm just like
I just want I don't want any heat for
being like why are you still talking
about how great Japan went wow yeah what
I was saying his muscles didn't negate
and where is yeah
yeah I mean obviously I mean you know
the public has spoken he became more
popular with his big muscles
you know what I mean yeah who else is
muscly Camille
camel doesn't do got it Rogan
does Rogan still understand him yeah
yeah in giant Arenas okay yeah him and
Chappelle
lemon Chappelle together comedy that's
right yeah both muscles yeah yeah they
both have muscles a lot of creatine bits
yeah they're looking at each other's set
list it's like I'm doing deadlift you
can't you can't open the devil you can't
do that I got to do that I want to talk
about
when I'm not eating
uh yeah I guess it you know but these
people are all like someone young coming
up with muscles
I don't know let's bring it back to us
me all of a sudden I show up with
muscles probably not great
I think it would be very funny
very very funny if a very gentle
I actually when we were talking about
jizz couch I had a marriage ref thing
for you and that's not even how I think
of you but it might it really isn't but
because you were the host of the
marriage ref in my first marriage
we only got I think we only got in one
it wasn't even a fight it was just a
heated discussion and it was about this
and I'd just love to hear you use your
expertise I do love doing this I I know
that it seems like and it's like a
natural place for you yeah and then just
to lead where we have to talk about
Vegas yeah of course we have to talk
about I can't wait to Taco in fact the
rest of the podcast will probably just
but we I really want to talk about that
trip it's good because I literally
[Music]
uh yeah I literally thought about it
last night because I was in a similar
situation really yeah I have an I have
an update too because this weekend I had
a situation that I thought was going to
be like our situation okay I can't wait
to talk about just the many different
ways just uh this is a teaser stand up
yeah you'll never figure it out you'll
never know what these these shifting
Sands of the stand-up lifestyle you
can't call it you don't call it you
can't that's a preview we'll come back
that's a preview right after this this
isn't ad but it is not good so just
my ex-wife and I were driving in my 2001
black Jetta tan interior show off
we're driving on the highway in Chicago
and my friend Chris Mars who's a very
funny comedian still is uh admired we my
first marriage we had all this furniture
from my parents like we didn't have any
furniture we didn't have any money so
our whole like kind of crappy apartment
had like huge Oriental Rugs right like I
remember that my desk chair had like
eagle head crafted and it wasn't arms it
was like two Eagles it's awesome leather
like studs like you know they got it in
New Hampshire and yeah loaded it on a
truck and now it's here in my apartment
and my friend Chris admired my desk
chair he was a little bit older than me
still is so he was like I love this
chair and then they were getting married
and we're driving and this is like that
sort of it's a little aspy it's a little
hyper literal I'm just going so I get
where I was coming from I've become a
little bit more aware of this blind spot
that I have okay which is the guy that
always wants to go to the same
restaurant the guy that like if if I
like this restaurant or it's on the way
to the club just go there every day by
the way we have to talk about swim
trunks don't forget swim trunks okay put
a pin in swim trunks okay but so I said
in that sort of way that I can be to my
ex with no awareness that that is a way
that I can be a little too practical
I was like well we don't know what to
get them for their wedding we don't
really have any money why don't we why
don't we give him the chair that he
wanted that I think I said he could even
have I think that makes it worse I was
like you can have it and then I was like
let's give it to him for his wedding and
she was like you can't do that that's
totally tasteless totally bad keep in
mind though as you refereed this is like
Nick Jr marriage ref because we were 22
and 24 at the time right babies yeah now
you'd be like what are you an idiot I
can't get how old was he he's probably
25 26. so I feel like we're still
College age enough to be like this is a
very expensive chair yeah it's your
wedding you want it that's my point
she's like you already said
fine with me as I say that no I don't
know if I side with me what what comes
to mind I
say yeah I say you're right I say fine
yeah 100 here's what you funny he's
funny yeah he's gonna see it and laugh
he's also going to appreciate that he
got that chair yeah no one wrinkle
and it's a problem that is worth it's
worth the bit I would say is the overall
and the one wrinkle that is still worth
the bit is that uh his
partner may not like it his partner May
hate it she probably would have hated it
she probably will hate it this ugly man
but they could they have a curb I'm sure
where they live where they could put it
out and get rid of it where you live
yeah I have a curve yeah had a guy come
and do the the painting letter they
paint it and then they say Harry painted
it no he asked first he said uh 20 bucks
to paint it and then um I was like yeah
okay I said his I literally just I was
tired I'm just like is this a scam in
any way is there any you just asked him
yeah is there a system in any way I
don't mind that you're doing it I just
want you're gonna do it you do it the
cops aren't gonna yell the DPW guys and
what did he say no it's good I just and
then he and that's what I want to say to
the candy and then his little flaw came
out which is that he likes to tell you
who everyone is in the neighborhood
there's a childhood Star right down
there and I did so-and-so's house down
there and you know this so-and-so is
your neighbor and then it was like oh
great so that's your little thing he's
just a little blabbermouth that's every
driver every makeup artist too by the
way I don't even mean it in a bathroom
yeah artists never stop being you I
always go who's a [__]
always the most fun question yeah
absolutely [__] and they will tell you
they can't wait to tell you they can't
wait to tell you and it's super fun your
parent your your friend had a curb I
would say give yeah give the chair it's
funny it's a good bit see you saw it he
might also like it he also might really
love it and put it in his office and
okay see if my wife would still be
together if she thought this way yeah
but if she went it's funny we should do
it yeah that would have solved
everything yeah because then I would
have been like oh no it's fun oh I
didn't even realize I was being funny
and then I would have walked back into
it and been like yeah let's do it as a
bit but I just meant that as an Earnest
experience as an Earnest like he really
wants this year again this is a good
gift like ver that's the tone that the
gift was the tone you just used you
really want this chair and here is a
chair I will be giving you this as a
wedding gift
they're still together
they're still together a long time ago
they went the distance yeah you always
want to be the couple that you ever ask
them do you ever tell them that you were
going to do it we didn't really stay in
that close to touch yeah well probably
because the chair where is the chair
great question so those antiques made it
and we're not going to talk about this
too long because people are here for
that sweet sweet Poppy
but we loaded up a moving truck and
moved to New York City so that stuff was
in Park Slope Brooklyn for a while then
we moved famously by the show crashing
we were living Upstate in Sleepy Hollow
so that chair made it quite a ways
here's how the chair dies oh no are you
ready yeah I threw no no my wife leaves
me she has an affair and I it was like a
symbol and I was always trying to push
some symbolism and crashing it it never
made it it just wasn't that kind of show
but I was like how funny is it that all
of this inherited Furniture yeah along
with all these inherited beliefs like my
religion and all this stuff stayed at
that house I just left
I don't know what she did with it if she
was uh Wicked smart should sell it
because it was like crazy ass antiques
but I remember my parents being like we
need those antiques those are expensive
Antiques and I was like they're never
going back to that house wow I went back
and like literally like a cliche I got
my joke notebook I got my PlayStation a
bag and yeah took a dumped and flush it
I know I didn't do anything like that on
fire but I I did think about like you
have those moments where you're like
aren't I supposed to do something wicked
yeah I didn't do anything Wicked ah you
just gotta get out of there we're too
polite well I let's let's give you the
credit that maybe you did do something
wicked by leaving that chair that she
was obviously against for some reason
and now it's her burden I it was her
burden and I bet if she sold it she sold
it for way less than it was worth
because that was almost like Antiques
Roadshow like you got to take this on
and be like this was Eisenhower's chair
because knowing her character you know I
know exactly what she did she sold it to
some she put it on the curb you think
she put on the curb
on this guy this guy's on the curb you
should have taken this kind of Agents
Roadshow don't like her at all this you
know what you find in my drawers a
letter a handwritten letter from Woodrow
Wilson like I'm a gem and you got rid of
me and you got rid of that chair you
gotta you got a Antiques Roadshow your
life before you get rid of it man I side
with you even stronger right now love it
need it yeah let's get to this okay
I don't normally guide it so strongly
but I really really really want to get
to our conversation last time I saw you
we were in Las Vegas I want to unpack
every detail but the one I want to start
with okay is that we were talking about
how
[Music]
how when you're like in Vegas both of
our wives will say things like bring
your swim trunks uh-huh do you remember
this yes did you bring your swim trunks
and you and I had this really it well it
was your it was just to clarify it was
when you we're always on the road we're
always doing gigs yeah and once in a
while your spouse your wife wants to
come and you want them to come but
you're also working so it's a little bit
of a thing and you say to yourself it'll
be okay
she can come she'll just meld into the
work of the thing and it'll be good and
as I was getting ready to take my wife
on one of those trips I'm in my office
and I'm getting all my Chargers and
whatever I got for the gig and I hear my
wife say from the other room are you
bringing your swimsuit
this is and I just went oh no that it's
she thinks we're going to have fun
buddy
I I forget what Val and I had just
discussed because it was something along
those lines and Val and I are we're best
friends one of those couples one of
those annoying couples I know
people hate it and they love it I love
it but like if there is a thing that
it's like operation we can't it's hard
you can't touch the side I'm gonna Buzz
it's this it's this issue yeah and we
were we're about to go to San Francisco
in January and Val is is Gonna Come and
I I find it so funny when you know you
have to ask a question but you know it
might upset the other person you know
what I mean yeah so she's going like
okay I want to acknowledge that it's
going to be tricky for you to think
about this but when we're in San
Francisco I would like to see my friend
capped and I immediately just like the
iron curtains of Darkness just clothes
inside of me where I just want to go and
she knows this by the way I'm not
talking out of school it's like she
knows that I'm like we're flying in that
day of the show of the show right you
get to the hotel you take a shower you
get dressed you go to the show no cat I
don't know why I'm doing with the
Seinfeld but I know he would agree no
100 I mean like and everyone knows this
too I'm getting in a Zone I know it
sounds stupid and it doesn't sound not
to you when I'm alone you just sit in
the room you might watch a little TV you
might like look at your notes but it is
about like bringing everything in you're
doing as you have work to do and then
you bring it on and it's yeah and it's
energy anything you want to spend it at
dinner with cat no cat the cat's gonna
ruin the show allergic to cat but that's
gonna ruin the show we solved the
problem by going after the show we can
seek out or you go see cat and I'll see
you later that's fair right I mean yeah
you can go see cat I I'm cool with that
I think I might have even gone that way
and she might have even gone that way
but then I was like maybe after the show
we could go see cat but you know what
I'm thinking we gotta get up in the in
the morning you know what the problem is
right there yes she's got you in a spot
where you're thinking
yeah all of a sudden you're you're
dealing with all of it you're dealing
with her you're dealing with that do I
feel bad does she feel bad am I okay am
I a dick for doing this should I just do
this what's wrong with cat and what's
wrong with me all of a sudden you're
thinking when you you would just be on
autopilot and just take your wheelie bag
in and that's over in fact that's the
whole okay so this past weekend
I did that it's so great a private show
yeah go ahead I did a private show in uh
North Carolina there's a birthday show
birthday show in North Carolina should
be bad private birthday private birthday
right I've done private birthdays we got
a bunch of money we love you we have a
birthday come on down yes I am rich my
wife likes you right please come perform
yep almost always goes not I'm gonna be
honest only the second time my career
it's happened I was like the first one
kind of weird uh no it was weird not a
great show yeah this one Tommy I
couldn't believe it it was good yeah it
was good sometimes they're good I was
out there and I was like what's going I
actually I surveyed them a little I was
like do you all know each other they
didn't all know each other so they were
able to become a crowd a little bit oh
that's good but I did not bring my
bathing suit and even come this is why I
brought it up to your point yeah coming
home this was yesterday okay my flight
was delayed three four times
Dallas Fort Worth connecting I had to on
the tram three times no tramming it
three times oh yeah yeah even even
old homsy yeah
if he's just doing one thing yeah happy
boy yeah I don't care whatever that's
what I'm saying what I'm saying is
that's not dinners with with cat that's
not uh making little plans I just have
to get home similarly when I'm doing
stand-up I just have to get to the show
I love that Clarity it's totally it's
clean now can I ask you
you on the uh on the trammy trams doing
that whole thing yeah which is a which
is a bear a mere mortal would be
freaking out uh
has your level of peace with those kind
of scenarios
changed since we've come back since the
pandemi
several pandemics yeah the pandemic
that's interesting
the first thing that comes to mind is
there is a base coat of I can't believe
I'm even at an airport it hasn't faded
like that I'm on a plane yeah that I'm
going places I still have that gratitude
yeah is that what what is your take yeah
I don't know if it's I I definitely am
experiencing it I'm experiencing more
calm you can't throw I've had some
insane like where American Airlines
cancel my flight at 5am on my way to the
airport and I have to be there that
night and I I'm changing Airlines and
I'm changing flights and I'm I literally
walk in after 12 hours of travel like
right onto the stage in the nick of time
but my stress level is not there it's
just like all right we're doing this
we'll see how it goes almost like seeing
it as an outsider in a way and just
being kind of like cool and calm with it
and I I know that it has shifted since
the break of
the pandemic
I don't know why I don't know if it's
gratitude I don't know if it's just it's
things are in perspective but there is
just this chillness to the road where
where before I would think I've got to
get there by I can't believe they
canceled my flight yeah I was never that
crazy but I would be feeling that for
sure in inside I don't have it wow yeah
I wonder it could be that it broke you
maybe the one that I like that I am
voting for that I believe it is yeah we
all kind of
it's hard to speak in general
generalities about the pandemic because
there's so many different experiences
but I would imagine that you got a
master class in surrender that's sort of
like snowed in feeling what was it
except not a canceled flight but a
canceled life and then you realize that
you still remained yeah that you were
okay you were okay yeah that's yeah
whereas before your identity was so
ironed on like a t-shirt
to what you do and that you show up and
that you get places and we all I mean
yeah my hope would be yeah that we all
saw see I'm working on this bed I'm
gonna run a bite okay it's it's based on
I was watching some I don't like it I'll
also I have that bit
sorry
he said
my only note is you said sorry too
quickly because that was very good that
was very funny I was watching it's in
success I was saying sorry because I
already had the bit not because of
interrupting you oh my God it was mine I
knew you were a fine aged wine
um it's on succession where uh Brian
Cox's character says everything I do I
do for my kids Mark Wahlberg on his
terrible reality show I say terrible
because it's just reality yeah uh he
also goes everything I do I do for my
kids right yeah and my my father three
Impressions my father everything I do I
do for my kids that's my father and uh I
always get really lit up when when men
especially successful men all three of
those examples are successful men that
are doing well
um say that what they do is for their
kids and there's a lot of reasons sure
but talk about identity one dad or Brian
or Mark if you stopped working you'd
vanish that's point one uh-huh you'd go
like it's death yeah yeah to lose your
your place your purpose or your power is
actually a better a better way to put it
yeah lose your power and part of that is
this is how I don't know how to make
this funny being a person who provides
for his kids is one of the cornerstones
of your identity so that's about you too
right do you see what I'm saying yeah
it's like your job is part of your
identity and and I provide for my kids
is also part of my identity I'm not
saying that's not a good thing to do I'm
saying at a certain point of success can
you please stop saying it's for your
kids and just go this is for me if this
is for me I have I have 400 million
dollars this is for me because isn't
that also a good lesson to teach your
kids like I want you to do things that
make you happy yeah and I'm going to
model that for you absolutely have to do
a private show I I mean I certain I
certainly do I build and all that sort
of stuff but like at a certain point
yeah why can't you just be like it's for
me and you happen to be here
it's for me and you happen to be here
all right when you give money to someone
on the street
yeah I want him to be but it's for you
but I feel I bet you I feel better than
he does
I'm going to guarantee that
as much as I walk away thinking what a
great how great am I yeah I mean come on
you get the hit I am pretty great and
it's not just yeah it's it's the thought
I'm the kind of guy who helps people in
need which is okay it's okay because now
you're helping people in need and we'll
take kindness however we can get it and
whatever your motivation is right and
you know what my father and Mark
Wahlberg and the fictional character of
Logan Roy did feed and and shelter their
families that's right but at a certain
point uh let's just stop nobody likes me
to say out loud that I love money and
accolades
so but I'm gonna say it's for the kids
that's exactly maybe it's a because I
love
well give me action I'm great
I love when people think I'm better than
them I love it I mean what's what's
better than being on a movies can you
imagine being on a movie set and you're
Mark Wahlberg and you're the star of the
movie Mr Wahlberg here's your herbal tea
get this out of here
I'm doing squats like it's the best is
this for my kids yeah and this these
spots for my kids they moved my gym on a
truck here it's for my kids right it's
for you to feel like a special baby boy
yeah just be more honest you love you
you made it funny yeah it's for me and
you happen to be here it's for me and
you happen to be here and I love money
right and uh I just love money the rush
of it if my father was just like Peter I
just love the ups and the Downs of it
way more than anything you've ever done
I mean like I don't know that's true
yeah uh but I worry that I've Had My
Moments with you yeah but when a big
contract comes in oh you pay off me but
when you're on the line for 50 large or
whatever it is
okay let's finish our Vegas let's not
even finish it let's start it yeah tell
me the story because you got that gig
first didn't you I had that gig first
yeah I've done that gig in previous
years they brought me back that's a
couple of times to do that gig this was
a liquor distributor yes one of the
biggest in the world and they wanted you
to do and I had come in
um before the pandemi before the
troubles uh I hosted like a multi-day
thing for them it was even much bigger
than when we were there and uh and I
hosted and was funny and charming and
they asked me to come back uh several
times to to do this event for them wait
this was like the third time you've done
it
wow yeah
because I love money but you're also the
perfect if somebody called me and was
like if I was invited to do something I
couldn't do it you would be the first
person I'd be like you know who you
really want yeah is Tommy P right the
cake and I'll I'll do okay in those
scenarios and that's about what you want
yeah this is what we're talking about oh
yeah this is a story about doing a
corporate gig which can go other ways it
can go any other ways you're grading it
on a different metric I was in one last
night and uh and I real and I was
talking about this morning with uh
fortune and
I said you grade these things
differently this isn't did I kill like I
killed anywhere else like at a theater
comedy club no if you kill in a
corporate environment once in a while
it'll be close to the theater experience
yeah but most of the times you got
through it right you got through it
because there's a large majority of the
people that are there that have they're
all there for work
a very small group loves comedy
a whole bunch of them don't care about
comedy don't like comedy don't see
comedy out don't know who comedians are
and now you walk and they're rich
sometimes they're rich this is when
they're working and they're in a they're
in a social hierarchy situation in this
environment where they're all vying for
position and now here comes Pete who's
going to tell you about his life and
what his cat feels like what is how his
relationship is with his kids and
they're like what do I give a [__] about
Pete and his his dating problems you I
came home I might have even said it to
you that night when I was doing that
show I've told the story before on the
podcast I didn't do well I didn't I
didn't like it wasn't an Abomination but
it wasn't going well right and I was
like the feeling in the room was why are
you telling us this because
I'm like this is not you're not right
I'm a cat person and you're looking out
at these multi-millionaire liquor sales
people and they're like
who who asks they're thinking this night
is about me this is about me I know I'm
in here with 500 600 a thousand other
people yes this is my company and I'm
gonna I'm gonna score tonight I'm going
up that elevator yeah and I nailed it
yes
hey you guys ever you ever open up your
toothpaste and have it
it's you you know you squeezed it but
it's not on your brush and now you're
fresh it kind of gets air in it it's
kind of like an air pocket and the guy's
like what yes who is this why is he
talking it actually the experience blew
holes in all of stand-up comedy meaning
stand-up comedy is a joint agreement
between the audience and the performer
to make something that isn't act that
shouldn't work right it shouldn't work
right when I come back and I go to the
store or I go to Largo and it's working
yeah since that gig I'm like this is a
miracle like that they sometimes laugh
at the first thing you say these these
guys yeah
but here's the thing you go into some of
those environments and they know a
comedian's coming
I'd lit you literally have to say for
the people at home you literally have to
say
when I get there do they know a comedian
is coming yeah and if they don't uh say
and now a comedian is coming to the
stage like you literally have to say
those the words it's a spell because
yeah because and now it's stand-up
comedy yeah now stand up so they can
adjust they should say and now stand-up
comedy is being asked of you right
you're going to participate you have to
do it right and it's so sometimes
sometimes you roll in and you can kill
these things for sure and brag they go
really I mean they can go well the
reason I was there was a month prior I
was in Vegas and did one and it went
well but like you said with the party
they didn't all didn't know each other
that's an advantage that's the key
because when you go to these corporate
things sometimes you're walking into a
culture that you don't know so if you
can one of the worst is like uh car
salesman those guys are all machismo all
and and they tell you you got to be
clean yeah and in front of these garbage
mouths swinging dicks yeah swinging
they're a bunch of swinging decks right
and if you're not as bigger than they
are which is you're not going to listen
to you I always hear stories that Tim
Allen sort of famously will come out and
be like they tell them don't be clean be
clean be clean and he'll like open with
the dirtiest thing like dirty to us like
right filthy to win them over oh 100
which is pretty great I
but you don't need the money that's what
I mean yeah at a certain point you're
like I don't need the money I need to do
well right and I know it's almost like
doing colleges can be this way too yeah
I know you actually want me to do this
right but it's a big play it's a big
play because they could say he you
breached yeah you breached and we're
paying you yeah
so those situations are are uh are
pretty precarious and I had one last
night I want to come back to what would
happen with you that night I feel like
we hit it I mean we know now own homes
that you've got the back sweat but when
uh when so last night I'm doing a
fundraiser at the Beverly Wilshire Hotel
for this beautiful organization that
helps uh women's Reproductive Rights all
around the world and I've done it for
like five years in a row and um and they
all know me as funny and I'm their guy
and I host the night and I love them
they love me and it's always great we've
had two years of not doing it live
because of the troubles and when I
walked in last night it was a different
crowd they asked me to come to the stage
and the place was in chaos in that grand
ballroom of the Beverly Wilshire Hotel
the places in chaos talking you know and
in years past when they say that coming
on they're like anticipating it and
wanting it and it goes great and I
walked out there and I had to substitute
teacher a little bit of yeah to quiet
them down
and then they all kind of like and look
I totally get it these people have not
been networking
for and this is all agents this is this
is all Showbiz people and they're and
they haven't been in rooms networking
like that in these events into so
they're all at this point in the story
yeah and I'm I'm actually surprised I
feel this way I feel cold Terror because
here's the predicament yeah
I'm thinking about my agents out there
yeah in their suits and they're talking
and they're excited and they're having
drinks and then you come out and you
shush and they do get quiet yeah but
there's almost this energy it's like the
the Hammer's been pulled back on a weird
hunting rifle yeah that you and them are
now on a stand-up you made them shut up
yeah and now there's almost like uh all
right like it's almost it could be
antagonistic well you've got it right
and you have to follow up the shush you
gotta follow up the shush and then they
still like want to keep talking and
there's a Podium there and I was like
okay now when I walk over to the podium
and I wasn't really chastising them I
was very cognizant of that so I walked
over the podium and there's some stuff
up on the um on the uh teleprompter
about the organization I said when I
come over here this is going to be
really important stuff because I'm going
to tell you about this group and how
they save 22 million
um uh women during childbirth and they
all listened it was all like quiet and
they applaud added when I got to like
the thing of like so and that's what
they do and they all clap and then I
wandered away from the podium and tried
to tell a joke about whatever about the
pandemic or something started talking
again started
it started just so and I walked backed
over to the podium and they got all
quiet and I said something great about
the leader of the organization and I
just
didn't realize I'm not going to kill I'm
not going to be a comedian this is about
hosting this is about I can get the job
done for the client
without but so I do it and I come off
and they're like oh my God thank you you
got the room in order and then the
leader came out and she spoke and it was
great and but this is the part that's
going to make you cold again oh no what
I find out sheer nightmare of who's in
the audience it's the head of Netflix
films it's the head of Warner Brothers
films it's
um uh uh Sean Levy the director Sean
Levy he's gonna be honored uh there's uh
Nick Kroll's about to do a set Brett
gelman's there uh Ken alterman's there
all these everybody and all of these
Executives from the tops of the agencies
it's a very heavy show busy thing and
they saw me be nice they saw me do a
good job he's a pro yeah
I'm not going and mingling with these
people the what the way I can have a
good night is to kill in front of these
people yeah and be like oh my God Pete
is amazing holy [__] Pete's funny that's
interesting so I just had to stand there
in the suit and be like
professional and good and Charming but I
didn't get to that's interesting but
that's not gonna that's not gonna bug
you that long it doesn't it doesn't mug
me that long and this is where I'm gonna
come back yeah
come back to you
in Vegas Your Instinct in Vegas was
what the [__] is wrong with you people
yeah this is I am I know what I'm doing
and what is wrong with you what I'll say
is hotline like I'll say a punchline
that I love and I go hotline and we just
let it go right by let me tell you Tommy
B it's a weird move for a guy whose
biggest fear is that people will find
out that there's ugliness inside of it
like it's weird to like go big yeah
you'd think I'd be like well streaks on
the China like just do whatever I wanted
just to like stay nice and be
professional yeah but something will
often it's a survival it's a fight
flight yeah and it's fight yeah and and
in Vegas you made it very funny in Vegas
because you you went so far into how how
badly this is going like right you can
do that a little bit yes and you went I
went way back yeah yeah yeah and we're
just like
oh my God I mean this is really going
horribly horribly wrong and and then you
would do it then you would go back and
do a joke and it would do well it did
what like legit did well yeah I felt it
that's what you were doing on the
monitor they were like that went well
and then I would still be like a few
people yeah I know it's even bigger than
that like you never ever let them off
and buddy I've done that whatever that's
called let's call it the rooster the
rooster comes out and I've done shows I
did a show for them for the rndc to
honor Julia louis-dreyfest who hopefully
is going to do the podcast and hopefully
we're going to talk about it because it
was she was wonderful but it was exactly
what you're talking about but I
I I wish I had played it yours which was
boring I went up I told my joke it was
nothing like it was death yeah and I and
Nick Roll was there a lot of the same
people were there and then I went full
rooster like real hard because what
happened was there was a couch where
Julia Louis uh Tony Hale and Val my wife
were sitting right and the more I spun
out they started literally falling out
of their chairs yeah like dying yeah and
I was like that's the only thing that's
working and I went real like this sucks
you guys [__] selling hard and then
afterwards I'm like oh every every
executive in the world Hollywood is at
this event and uh so that so wait so do
you think that they do you think that
they appreciated that buddy I I still
think about it yeah and I go I was I
went on Instagram not that long ago and
noticed that Julia Louis drives followed
me and I was like oh I think so Julia
Louis I liked it yeah and I talked to
her afterwards and she liked it but I
did not mingle the room and the people
that did come up to me were were of the
spirit of like that was so funny what a
weird crowd but like like um well then
Casey boys are from HBO like the head of
of development yeah HBO was there he
comes up to me and he's like yeah these
things are always weird but I was like
uh I don't know I did like I know it
filled me with uncertainty but I'll tell
you
because what you're bringing to mind is
you're also plagued if you play it safe
like I think I also would have been
plagued if I was just kind of like is
this thing on and I at least made so
yeah at least the question I had hosting
stuff to go do so I I could just bail on
trying to throw more joke pitches and
having them Miss right I just had to do
Stanley you had to do stand up so
there's like you you just have to but
the question is is so you have to huh
what were you saying
you have to do your act I think is what
you're gonna do yeah like when you're in
that situation where you just have to do
the jokes well the thing is jokes this
is the comfort that Val gave me
afterwards is like if we had seen
someone else do what I had done we would
have loved it and thought it was the
stuff of Legend right like literally
yeah it's the sort of stuff that's like
in a documentary where you're like yeah
look at this and I was like maybe it
looked cool that's all I had I was like
maybe like those executives are like
that crazy cat
the not noticing yeah that really
because the the pretending it's not
happening is death buddy that night the
rooster
with the birth not the birth of the
wrist The Roosters come out a lot uh but
usually the rooster is whatever not in
front of a bunch of executives I
recognize that like I got in to stand up
to be honest about what's happening
right exactly and and I actually felt
like too much this sounds crazy but
almost like Jackson Pollock or something
but I was like it's too much of an
artistic compromise it's not even a
compromise it's a wilting it's a death
yeah if I go like and what else is going
on
fortune cookies they don't really give
you a fortune do it like I had to be
like this is death like I'm dead I hate
this this sucks this sucks and again
yeah three most important people to me
we're we're enjoying it right but I
like I'll I'll say like a week later I'm
going wait what what was that why did I
do that because I was probably in a
better mood like a week later
to not read it if you're not if if
you're in your own if the roosters just
spinning and and knocking things around
yeah
uh which was happening in Vegas a little
bit the rooster came out the rooster was
kicking over the podium yeah and I know
for a fact they were enjoying it more
than the rooster thought that's the
problem with the rooster yeah and and I
think even Val said a lot of people were
like you just couldn't hear the lamps
and that's what you guys told me in
Vegas right this is why the rooster
bunny is a very confusing
side of my psyche but I think it's it's
a it's an exaggeration I might even say
a perversion of something that you need
to do stand up which is like like
grotesque
confidence taken too far turns into the
rooster yeah or that like Live Free or
Die snake like I'm just like I'm gonna
at least be honest or I'm gonna die yeah
I don't know but yeah that did happen I
mean like you said earlier like it's so
complex like these things are so complex
yeah because they are because
uh were you were they enjoying it more
than you thought were you uh where were
you
um trying to burn it down just to
because that was funny to and you just
knew to you yeah that I was watching
well that's that's what I'm saying
happened in the other one yeah was I'm
like Julia Louise watching you're
watching and and there becomes this
other game literally of chicken it's
very appropriate it's called the rooster
where you're like I'm gonna but like I
never I know we're talking way too much
about me but I never thought I'd be a
guy that would be like one of the moves
is I'll just smoke and I'll be on fire
and I'll curse you all as I crash into a
mountain but no one will say nothing
happened you know what I mean right
they'll be damned if you say nothing
happened I watched a guy sweat and die
I'm like no if the show has watched me
burn the show is watch me yeah yeah I
just It's Tricky I mean like for me last
night you know
I'm driving home and
I want those I want all those people to
think that oh my God he is so funny
which every other year it was but that
group was so loud and boisterous and
eyes the host of this thing for two
hours I'm in no position to start
attacking them yeah and it would be
unjustified it would just be my ego
because yeah they're in they're in a
they're in a networking situation that
they haven't been in yes in years
they're excited they're supporting this
group they're going to spend thousands
of dollars it is
Tommy pops is not the headlining part of
this not about me I concede with joy
feeling seen what's challenging to a
spiritual person about the rooster is
you're like God damn there's a big ego
like though in fact the whole Allure to
the spiritual practice that I have
is probably because you're like wow look
that pillow as my [__] name on it you
know what I mean like we're dealing with
something that needs to be dealt with a
lot of people won't deal with it yeah a
lot of people that aren't in Show
Business have huge egos but that is
probably why even more than the like
maybe they didn't like me there's this
fear that you're like there is something
like disgusting in me you know what I
mean like and I think we all kind of
share that fear
the fear is I'm too much if people see
me I'm too much it's whatever well I'm
overwhelming I'm too loud I'm too pissed
I'm too bad right like it's just like
everybody's like [__] take it easy
and that's the weird kid in junior high
yeah yeah I mean
in earlier days I would have
I would have last night would have
messed that situation up would have been
pushing the jokes and then starting to
say like what's wrong with you yeah yeah
and
that wasn't my place for the reasons I
stated and when I was driving home
I was kind of I wasn't I was a little
bummed that I didn't get to show off and
kill and have a fun night and have these
directors and head of Studios be like
who's that guy again yeah uh but
I they all
came up after like what a pro yeah thank
you for doing that for the organization
and then Nick Roll I set up Nick to do a
set and
um and um all this other stuff and like
I was I was at least I wasn't I wasn't
Overjoyed because I didn't get what I
wanted out of it but I was proud of
myself that I was a pro and kind of kept
my ego in check to make the night like
okay for the others yeah you know what I
mean that's interesting because I was
hosting mine yeah I brought up Nick
it was actually there's more to the
story Leslie Jones went up and made what
I did look like kindergarten and she and
but she did it brilliantly but like I
was so grateful to her right because she
actually roasted everybody she was
making fun of everybody like directly
their appearance their date their their
dumb laughs and I and like and it was
yeah it was intense and then you know
who did go up and was the Tom Papa was
Nick Kroll Nicole went up and actually
did well with bits and addressing what
had happened like making fun of the
night making fun of us a little bit well
a lot easier no discredit so Nick but I
mean you guys kind of hammered it and
made it into a crowd they were like oh
okay yeah dude you're making me remember
before the show tignataro was so relaxed
that she was bothering me how relaxed
she was because I was like this is
outside it's at 6 00 p.m it's on Sunset
Boulevard it's loud like well this is
going to be bad and she was like don't
you see that none of this matters and I
was like how is that helping me and I
was like do you want a house and she was
like yeah I don't care and I was like
great you host and like I think they
didn't want to swap the order but I
didn't want to go first yeah at all and
I to your point I would have much rather
batted cleanup well this goes back to
the thing we were saying about
you being in Dallas on the five trains
and not being stressed you oh oh yeah
right yeah
I think that
it's it's close to the thing of being in
that thing last night and being like
all right it's one of these yeah it's
one of these that's it's you know what I
mean like being closer to the tick of it
all managing the expectations yeah and
just being like we've done all this okay
can I tell you this though this is
interesting so Largo my Largo show was
was a couple nights before my birthday
show and all month I've been like Largo
I haven't done it in two months did I
miss your birthday
what no the birthday show oh
you know in North Carolina the one we're
talking about oh thank God
but all month I was like Largo is going
to be gangbusters and that birthday show
is going to be death right and then
because Largo I noticed this phenomenon
if the ticket is over 20 bucks or 30
bucks if it's 50 bucks yeah I swear to
God I can tell that it's a 50 ticket
like you just feel there's a little
tightness
this is fifty dollars like oh really
where it's I would think it would be the
opposite like we are gonna have fun no
matter what that would be wiser yeah
that would make more sense yeah I've
done a lot of shows at Largo where the
ticket is a is a jacked up benefit show
ticket right and almost every time and
sometimes I don't know and I go out and
I go what's going on and they're going
and I'm like oh it's how much was the
ticket I asked him like how much was the
ticket yeah and I did that at my show
but like the rooster came out just a
tiny bit tiny rooster lowercase rooster
just being like what is this what I
needed and it worked and it got the show
going it was a great show and then by
the middle of the show I'm just doing
bits normal bits yeah having a great
time but then when you because of that
show I remembered what you remember
which is like manage your expectations
yeah stop expecting it to be like other
things yeah just let it be what it is by
the way this is like the ABCs of a good
life yeah it's not just good sets no
kidding stop expecting 100 anything yeah
and just but now I'm backstage in a jazz
club in North Carolina and I'm like
don't expect anything right just see see
how it goes then you go out right you do
the first joke and they're like what the
[__] they laughed yeah and then and then
you roll and now you're actually happy
and now Happy Chicken not rooster Happy
Chicken comes out I might instead of
riffing being like where are you I'm
going like you guys are so great oh you
didn't like that one you're so
compassionate like this like Happy
Chicken I always want to be happy
chicken but the truth is I wouldn't have
become Happy Chicken if I hadn't
remembered rooster on Thursday then
Happy Chicken came out on Sunday because
like I kind of need those the bumper
ball bowling that that corrects my ball
a little bit it gets me in the center of
the lane
yeah
there's also I mean ego's a big part of
it you know because I think that's what
we're talking about yeah because you
I had one that was far worse okay since
I saw you put a pin in that we're gonna
do the mid-rolls and we when we come
back I will be right back I feel like
I've been telling these horrible stories
finally Tommy P I'm just kidding you
know we're in it together okay here
comes Tom Papa we'll be back in
literally two minutes
pardon the interruption weirdos we will
literally be back to Tom Papa in one
minute let me just tell you I was just
talking to somebody about ketamine
therapy and how much it changed their
lives and let's be honest you just need
to take better care of yourself is not
an appropriate response for people
struggling with their mental health you
know you live with it sometimes you need
something more to achieve a real and
Lasting breakthrough well maybe it's
time to check out a guided ketamine
Therapy Program from our friends at
mindbloom the struggles we face for our
mental health can Loom large over our
lives maybe even yours maybe someone you
love maybe you've tried everything or
have you mind Bloom is the solution for
the next chapter in mental health and
well-being mind Bloom is the leader in
at-home ketamine therapy offering a
combination of science-backed medicines
with clinician and guide support for
people looking to improve their mental
health and well-being mind Bloom
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes which lower
costs greater convenience and an
artfully crafted experience to begin you
take mind Bloom's online assessment and
schedule a video consult with a licensed
clinician to determine if mind Bloom is
right for you if approved you'll discuss
your health history and goals for mental
health and treatment with your clinician
to tailor your mind Bloom regimen mind
Bloom will then send you a kit in the
mail complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after listen to
this after only two sessions 87 percent
of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in depression and 85
percent reported improvements in anxiety
so it is time to end sorry it is time to
enter the next chapter in mental health
and well-being let mind Bloom guide you
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com
ymiw like you made it weird y-m-i-w you
and use promo code ymiw at checkout
that's go to mindbloom.com ymiw promo
code ymiw for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today One Last
Time mindbloom.com ymiw promo code ymiw
this episode is also brought To Us by
our friends at Pym choose for those of
you watching the video I'm holding up
the delightful yellow box right now p-ym
prepare your mind these shoes help you
manage feelings of stress anxiety and
overwhelm it's wonderful I love it I
swear by it when you're feeling worried
when you're feeling stressed out or as
we like to say on we made it weird Val
and I always talk about having a bee in
your belly I can't tell you how many
times I just can't quite put my finger
on what's going on but I just feel a
little bit underwater stressed out and I
get a little bit fight Freeze I'll
freeze and I won't be able to do
anything pop in two of these delicious
natural Citrus flavored no sugar added
chews and really within minutes you
start to feel more centered calm and in
control I love them so much as soon as I
tried them the first time I subscribed
my mom and my brother just so happy to
find something for anxiety and stress
that is natural non-addictive and
non-psychoactive a solution that is just
that simple I like taking it the start
of my day that eases me into whatever it
is I have to undertake but I also take
them at the end of the day to help me
wind down and relax away the stress of
the day how does it work Pym shoes are
comprised of proven amino acids this is
not woo-woo this is straight science
these complexes and adaptogens help
support your brain and your body's
ability
to organically support and manage and
tolerate stress anxiety and overwhelm it
helps your body systems do what they're
designed to do but it gives them that
little boost I also have been trying
some of their new products this is Pym
mood magnesium a dietary supplement it's
Amino infused magnesium to support
stress again cognition and sleep
again this is something I take in the
morning in my smoothie rounds out the
edges of my day rounds out the edges of
my inner reality and also again at night
helps me to fall asleep I just watched a
video about how powerful and effective
magnesium can be and what a better
alternative it is to taking some
over-the-counter sleep solution 70 or
something percent of adult Americans are
deficient in magnesium it is a huge huge
huge help and a secret weapon in my
Arsenal their mood magnesium was
formulated by neuroscientists and
nutritional psychiatrists it includes
three magnesiums with the most evidence
to support their effects on stress and
sleep manganese l-theanate malate and
glycinate it's very effective in helping
me fall asleep faster sleep throughout
the night and wake up feeling rested I
can attest I took it last night and went
out like a baby with no effort it's
delicious and easy to use thanks to the
Yuzu flavored power both of these
products products guys Pym is on a
mission to end the stigma surrounding
mental health and to make a better mood
accessible to all and a percentage of
their profits one percent goes towards
mental health non-profits including
bring change to mind so
get a little bit more control over your
stress your overwhelm and your sleep and
your overall health by going to you
kenpym.com weird and use promo code
weird for 15 off and show your support
of the show again that's you can pym.com
weird use promo code weird for 15 off
and show your support of the show all
right let's get back to town Papa
and we're back Don Papa what happened
what do you mean I was there no I was in
Salt Lake City doing this gig and it was
they had me go up in a uh
what essentially was a cocktail party
for 500 people all standing up
there's a stage but all standing up a
photo booth two open bars in the room oh
no with people getting hammered and and
drinking and this is their first night
there and they're all seeing each other
and they're all doing a thing
and I mean it made last night's at the
Beverly Wilshire scene like like they
were paying attention
this was a like a keg party in high
school and they introduced me and they
said just go up and do your thing
and unlike the Tim Allen thing of like
I'm just gonna I'm like
I have to do 20 minutes
and I think it was a half hour
and uh this is just one of those and I
went up there and there and when I'm
walking around there are people like
taking selfies with me because I'm there
and so I stand up there and I see Pete I
see like
eight ten people creeping to the stage
laughing
and the rest of the room is ah oh my God
and
I was like
all I can do this is a [__] show this is
insanity
my ego wants to say I'm not doing this
but the giving part of me said these six
people that took selfies with me
are laughing and I'm just going to tell
some jokes to them and make a comment
about what's happening in the room and
I'm just going to put a smile on my face
because
I just don't want to disappoint these
six people that are actually here paying
attention can I just say this is I
really think I know we're talking about
stand up yeah but being able to make
that calm decision
is just to I think that's actually what
we're talking about it is what we're
talking about a Moment of clarity where
you go like I could go shut the [__] up
shut the [__] up and like make it about
you or you just go like ah I learned
that early doing outdoor shows before
the pandemic made outdoor shows somewhat
palatable
I remember like you always feel like
you're bombing Outdoors because it's
open air and it feels horrible yeah
but I would see people's faces and they
were like smile and I was like oh I'm
the one I'm the one person who hates
what's happening now they're actually
okay don't assume this is hell for them
and just do your act and put a smile on
your face and walk out and then people
are like wow that was great and you're
like it was the worst day of the year
for me
but just pretend
of that before it shows that'll be my
rooster uh repellent yeah because like I
do
again I love how passionate and how
locked in and how even erratic I can
it's it's a like I said it's a
superpower it's just like this
undulated
but I'm like yeah the best shows I have
I've been listening to Father Greg Boyle
who founded Homeboy Industries wrote
three books and they're just beautiful
books and every story is a story about
putting someone else before you yeah I
don't mean it's not saccharin like
Chicken Soup for the Soul not to put
those books down I'm just saying like it
it they're real they're real stories
about sacrifice or or bonding or loss or
or and then that brings people together
this brings people together some lesson
they're all about humility to be honest
so many of them are just about like
sharing your advantage being humble and
finding joy and unexpected unexpected
sort of broken places and I I was
texting with Father Greg I was like I
used to think that what I need to do
before a set is look at my notes and now
I realize I need to go on a walk and
listen to a book like one of yours yeah
or similar yeah his are the best ones I
found because it's really about
I used to I what I said then was opening
my heart
but what I'm realizing in this
conversation is it's not just opening my
heart it's about making my heart so big
that it squashes down my ego to a a
small small I don't need as much of him
to come up with me as I thought I did
you don't need them at all I would say
yeah but
that also but he's interrupting myself
with the question I was going to ask
yeah go ahead which is
um
there is a certain amount of him that
has to be present or at least he's got
to be in the back seat because you know
it's you know you're the one person
standing up there with a microphone like
there has there is a certain amount of
ego that even gets you into the position
of thinking that you talking about your
cat in front of a place that doesn't
care about you is even a thing you would
even consider immediately going through
yeah so like you need it
but how but
in its right place well it's funny they
say back seat because if I had opened up
my heart before the Vegas show that
doesn't mean I could have just gone out
and been like look at you supplying
liquor that's so nice of you guys to
make sure we all have liquor like I
couldn't just do that the ego would have
had to jump into the front seat and
calmly drive like because he's the one
that can go like I'll do the brave thing
I'll I'll bite the bullet yeah and take
the pain yeah
it's about survival in those situations
so you're like whatever it takes right
but you know when I was watching you in
Vegas I was like
the overriding thing for me was he's
doing better than he thinks he is
because I knew it was a bit that you
were ripping them apart but also I knew
you weren't feeling it yeah you got to a
point where you weren't allowing
yourself to realize yes you had actually
dug yourself out right
right you would yeah and the headline
here is taking it all way too seriously
you know what I mean like why somewhat I
I think I well taking myself too
seriously not necessarily the show right
right right like the experience I will
say the the highlight of that show for
me and when I got the biggest laugh in
Vegas was when I said to this group of
sales people don't feel bad for me right
I'm I said opd's gonna sleep great after
this show and I was like and don't act
like you haven't been exactly where I've
been where you're trying to sell
something and it's just not connecting
yeah but then I looked at my set list
and it said like
[__] coffee and I'm like these people
do not care about my thoughts on coffee
yeah where you're like I hate when you
know that there is something you could
do and sometimes you're not allowed to
do it like there were there were new
invitations on what you could talk about
you couldn't be dirty this that yeah
right exactly I mean when the beautiful
part of it is and you always have to
remind yourself when you go into these
things a pitch meeting a set
um a podcast whatever and you're
stressing on your way and it's like you
have to remind yourself I'm funny like I
I'm my whole adult life is being funny
it's being funny it's gonna be oh and
that's what was cool about watching the
rooster take control was you aren't
going to be funny talking about coffee
you were going to be funny doing this
other thing that no one hired you to do
that's the joke but they did hire Pete
Holmes yeah and Pete Holmes brought this
version of that tonight and he's doing
this and he's ripping the thing down and
he's going into the self-deprecating
thing to depths that you haven't seen
yeah and it was like and it was great
and that's why those there were moments
of greatness yeah but then unfortunately
I'd be like ah [__] I gotta go back to
my ass
you know I appreciate it did well before
you you did do well but I had the
advantage of being with them for a long
like they knew me yeah they were like I
should have taken a note uh from just
like because I was watching and I was
like they're not giving him enough yeah
like I was like this isn't enough but
but that's a weird state on a curve
those things have to be graded on a
curve that's right but that was kind of
killing no I I completely agree but
going back it's this line I believe it's
from Chinese and the great way is not
difficult for those who have no
expectations meaning and the thing that
you and I always talk about from the
last time you're on the podcast is like
you and your family were going to go out
for the Fourth of July just to recap
real quick and and you had that voice of
your parents being like it's the fourth
of July there's going to be nowhere to
park there's going to be tons of traffic
it's going to be too loud it's going to
be hard to leave and then you went you
parked you watched you drove home it was
easy yeah and I was like that these
things the thing that you said all those
years ago and what we're talking about
now yeah are related and the power like
I really mean literal power that you can
seize over your life and have a better
life it sounds like I'm Tony Robbins
right now but I'm just saying like the
key
of humility humility is having no
expectations and and arrogance and ego
is having expectations you know totally
and like that so I'm just saying for
people listening very few people
listening do corporate comedy right yeah
yeah but everybody listening knows when
you go to a party you go on a date you
go to a job interview you go to a job
you go to anything and if you have or
even smaller than that
um going to the store sitting in traffic
having a conversation with a stranger
booking a flight whatever right like
it's it's it's in all of those things
it's in every it's literally in
everything you do that's why old homsy
when I literally traveled all day
yesterday and had no problem right
that's an easier and I've seen I've been
there where comedians are losing their
mind because a flight is delayed I have
a much easier time squashing that ego
the voice of the ego that says I should
be home I want to be home your American
Airlines you're supposed to get me home
yeah I don't have any problem with that
but when you bring my my
comedy into it suddenly I'm like you
like sometimes you know what one of my
save lines is I go you have no idea how
I think it should sound right now like
up here yeah like in my mind the laugh
this should get yeah you'd lock me away
yeah but conversations like this make
that go away
I watched this uh
I was in some place and I was watching
um is this place you old this place was
a bad hotel in Northern California and I
was watching this weird Comedy Channel
and they were showing
comedians I might have said this to you
comedians of um Paula Poundstone Louis
Anderson's generation yep and
it was a bad TV show and it was like a
series of them it was it wasn't like uh
evening at The Improv but it was
something like that it might even been
out of Canada I don't know but uh I was
watching they were all such Pros
and I watched Louie Anderson come out
and tell a joke and it nothing and the
second one nothing and you see in his
eyes because you know as a comedian you
see in his eyes
I'm on TV and I two jokes out of this
short set just whiffed
I'm in trouble but he never shows you're
in trouble only a comedian would see
that little glint in his eye yeah yeah
and he just bared down and made a
chuckle into the thing and and dug
himself out of the hole and had a good
set at the end but like you saw him yeah
not lose you saw and there was an
Elegance to that
okay this is my favorite conversation
I've had in a while it's how to bomb
well and I actually think one of the
keys to life is learning Richard Royce
has the point of Christianity is to
learn how to lose well meaning like die
well like yeah be humiliated be humbled
and be broken well yeah we're having an
interesting conversation I'm going to
add to your Louie Anderson I watched uh
Bill Hicks in Montreal it was um it's a
famous special where he goes the news
like all those [__]
and if the rooster watches that special
I'm like this crowd [__] sucks it's a
festival crowd yeah I've seen too many
shows they're leaving this guy out to
dry right and Bill Hicks King rooster if
there ever was one like who's always
gonna be real yeah knew how to throw it
in a gear he what he's sweating yeah and
I don't think he's just sweating because
he's hot I think he's sweating because
it's also like you see it where are
these idiots not these idiots but see
that's the voice what's happening right
now what's happening right now right and
he's a better way to put it right what's
happening right now what's happening
right now is it which is a better
question instead of listen to how I
phrased it what's wrong with these
idiots right how about what's happening
right now exactly that's an epiphany
you're listening to me having an
epiphany me too instead of what's wrong
with these idiots just simple what's
happening right now what's happening
what's happening right now because I
know what I do yeah and I know how this
normally goes yeah what is happening
right now and let's assess it and figure
it out and get through it and then no I
get angry about it and have the humility
didn't maybe go I don't know what's
happening right now here's the other one
so then I go to the store like maybe a
week after I saw you in Vegas and I am
trying to recalibrate and get my rooster
in check yeah and I'm sitting in the
back and this young woman who was very
funny went up on stage to host and her
whole set was was these people just
letting her whiff whiff good jokes yeah
like solid jokes she was performing she
was present she was right on and I'm
just going like what is this and then
Tommy P I swear to God like a voice of
Christmas Past was like don't you
remember this is what it is like for
most of your career oh yeah you were her
yeah and guess what every once in a
while you're still gonna have to be even
Louie Anderson doing the TV taping or
Bill Hicks taping is special or old
homsy in Vegas yeah out and then
sometimes the birthday show is going to
be fantastic this is what I mean the
shifting stands of stand up but what a
good classroom or playing field for us
to exercise these these exercises I'm
going to say exercise these exercises
because in in like your everyday life
it's uh if you know the thing about
what you were saying like why you
struggle with it in those mods because
it's as a comedian you're supposed to
tell the truth about what's happening
right now right so like it's it's that
when you're around the house or when
you're you know at the store or what
what all that stuff yeah you know what I
mean it's like
you mean that's the appropriate time to
do that you should be doing that all the
time yeah it should always be a little
detached from yourself which really
means
your ego isn't in the driver's seat yeah
you're watching yourself you're just a
little bit like
why am I
why you know what What's Happening Now
what's happening some guy just cut me
off and we took the you know just cut me
off in in line and just got one up on me
and yeah whatever it's not uh
it's not that important and it's not
it's it's not your ego that's happening
it's if you're able to detach from it
then like that whole attitude of seeing
it and then you're living your life with
a sense of Elegance I agree not just not
like you're set it's funny that you say
that a lot of spiritual things that I've
studied are like let's say let's call it
right-minded wrong-minded or or ego or
witness or whatever you want to say yeah
but they say that being right-minded or
being centered might be a good way to
say it is noticing that you're not
centered but not judging it right but
like you have that detached like you
said backseatedness yeah yeah where you
go like like I can be like oh Tom you
didn't but I'm like you hurt my feelings
but I can also not justify how I feel
does that make sense yeah yeah there's a
difference with me just kind of calmly
noticing that a chemical reaction I'm
not putting down emotions I'm saying I
had an emotional response but to justify
it means to really fill up that suit and
be like and this is me as opposed to
just going like hey this is what's
happening right now but I'm not I'm not
all stuck up in it right it does you're
meaning your behavior might not even
completely change you just might do it
differently you just might still tell
you you hurt my feelings instead of just
being like I am one with everything
right okay
you don't uh nail your identity to it
right right interesting yeah I mean you
know whenever you think of these like
zen-like states of like getting through
your life uh
I always slip into well I can't do it
because then I'm powerless and then I'm
just like letting people run over me or
I'm you know just uh you but you can
have strength and power while also it's
actually more powerful if you don't take
the bait and you don't get pissed at the
guy who cut you off or you right you
know what I mean father Greg would say
he does say in those books that I just
mentioned it's like
it's not I don't want people to mistake
my kindness for weakness he's like
kindness is the only strength right it's
like everything else is just an illusion
of just like banging pots and pans and
completely losing yourself right and uh
Course in Miracles is talk about being
defenseless is actually the because if
I'm defending myself I'm validating that
I'm being attacked which reinforces the
idea that I am vulnerable and and just
increases fear but being defenseless is
actually the only safe position right
you can't you can't really necessarily
take that literally in the sense that
I'm defending myself by taking this
breath you know what I mean like yeah
keeping myself alive but there is a
there's a status that you can have that
you see in people like Eckhart Tolle and
stuff take not Han when they asked him
about like what would you do if you got
attacked like if somebody punched you
and his answer was really interesting he
was like let me teach you how to be in a
place where people won't want to attack
you that doesn't mean monks by the way
famously have been murdered and assured
but he's saying there's a way that you
can kind of go with the river so much
that you yeah blend into the background
so much that no one would pick you
obviously I'm saying that's not always
really true I have a I have an
interesting thing kind of related to
what we're talking about I'll throw it
at you just to see what you what you
think there's we have uh we have dogs
that we have to walk around
um to the end of time in our
neighborhood and um there's a guy and we
have a black lab who's a big black lab
she's a the sweetest thing on the planet
just these big cookie dough eyes and
just wants to love on everything and
there's a guy why are you telling me
though
why are you telling me about your dog
I'm the audience in Vegas who cares and
there's a guy that walks a golden
retriever
through the neighborhood actually he
doesn't walk it his wife walks it he
walks ahead of her and marches and looks
for trouble and my dog loves golden has
a best friend Golden Retriever and I
think every time sees this golden
retriever wants to go and say hey are we
playing today and the guy sees it as my
dog is out of control and attacking
and he like marched he makes his wife
walk the dog behind and he like just
walks up ahead like who's gonna and my
wife exactly what we're talking about
and my wife has walked
um has walked him walked our dog and he
lunged at the at the guy my dog jumps
when he's when she sees you like wants
to hug you and jumps up it's not
attacking anyway yeah did that to the
guy and he got all like what are you
doing this is your dog is out of control
and like yelled at my wife when she was
alone
and they got into a fight a verbal fight
and my wife was like the dog is fine he
just loves your dog what what is the
problem here and they got in this huge
fight and I
walk the dog a week later I come around
a turn and he's marching ahead with his
wife my dog kind of like oh like leaps
doesn't come close to us if he didn't
hear anything before yeah and he goes he
says uh this is what I'm talking about
I don't want that dog coming after me
and I snapped
and I said oh you're the guy
I said you're the guy that attacked my
wife
when she was walking these dogs you're
the guy that came after my wife when she
was walking in her neighborhood and let
me tell you something
you go near her again I am calling the
police on you how dare you attack a
woman like that what I do what I didn't
you're going to call the like I'm
calling the police on you keep walking
keep walking big man tell me pops and he
goes
you said keep walking big man yes and
just and had and you threw out a big man
threw out a big man
what who attacks a woman out on the
street big man
so I have this that's worse and that's
just but it but I was proud of myself
that I didn't just say hey like I'm
gonna [__] come and get you or I'm
gonna punch you or I didn't threaten him
I just kept it in what it was which was
he threatened this woman and my wife and
this is on you it's not on us
so fast forward my wife has another
thing she's feeding the uh we have a guy
that gives out treats to the dog so
they're off leash right now at this
guy's yard and they come a rant marching
around the dog goes running they have
another fight
they have another fight but my neighbor
is like this big dude and he calms
everything down he's like there's no
problem whatever so she has her second
fight with this guy
he wait even after Tommy P let out the
rooster this guy we can't be his only
problem no one walks in this stance
without he's looking right that's what I
mean right if you're defending that's
right you're right confirming that you
are that it's killer be killed right
exactly everything about you says the
world is killer bee so let's go where
we're gonna fight we're gonna we're
taking a martial arts course because we
want to fight and the fight started for
him that morning in the kitchen you know
what I mean like right he was looking at
his refrigerator like how can this hurt
me yeah the elevator the cars the people
100 it's a lens yes it's 100 alone we're
not the only ones he's running into No
in fact whoever he runs into you can run
into Fred Rogers and you'd be like what
do you mean your neighbor yeah all right
so so we have that situation now I'm
like I said I have to walk these dogs to
the end of time two times a day they've
got to go
make huge huge shits just all over the
neighborhood
like like you won a terrible goldfish
why what has happened to my life yeah
I'm walking
I see them
I'm passing them
I see him
he's puffed he gets his Puff and I go
chest puff yeah and I pull Bella in a
little tighter
not not you know you don't want to
instigate she's not noticing
and I I have to live in this
neighborhood
I have to do this like to the end of
time and I go Happy Thanksgiving
you went the other way I went Happy
Thanksgiving
hey you too
and his wife goes Happy Thanksgiving she
like just so relieved that
we have this we have this route we can
take Oh Happy Thanksgiving
you should come over I'll have the cops
pick you up and take you to us
three days later
I'm walking there's this one tree that
has leaves falling in our that has like
fall-like leaves like the one piece of
three by three thing that looks like
fall Yeah in our neighborhood yeah
they're coming down the thing they're
coming down the opposite way I can't
handle how many times you're running
into these people I know I can't handle
it I can't someone change the route this
is my this like I live here you live
here he I know he doesn't why are you on
my route change the route change the
route I see them coming down the thing
uh they get into the street to walk
around me
all right see him and I said uh
you might want to come back on this side
of the street it's the one piece of fall
you're gonna get this season it's all in
that tree what
that one tree looks like Autumn you
should you might want to come back over
here he goes oh it's pretty nice
I'm dead that you're confusing this man
into kindness oh what what
it does
Laura this is the third one this is all
like within a couple weeks uh there's a
blind spot where you turn when I go back
home and he's come and it is a tricky
spot you got to go wide if your dog's
leading and he's there and I saw them
walking and I know we're gonna I just
did my whole head I'm thinking we're
gonna hit him at the blind spot and we
come up a thing and I go wide and he's
at the blind spot in front of his wife
and I said uh
I said those those tight Cur those tight
turns will kill you you got that's a
high risk area you're in it goes that's
why I walk first I was like good job
[Laughter]
wait
you got a little glimpse into the
philosophy yeah
he's walking ahead he's proud he walks
it we learned a lot we did learn a lot
it's not like whoops I'm walking ahead
like I do it because tight turns will
kill you yep my wife's gonna get knocked
over
and I'll go first so it is he's a detail
he's not a husband he's a detail uh what
do you mean a security detail oh right
yeah Secret Service the Secret Service
and you're the kind of Shmoe that he's
trying to eliminate not totally wrong
oh my God but I've just been now I've
been coming so this is what I'm just I'm
I can't walk out
it's picking up this [__] is enough of a
burden we don't have to also be Kung Fu
Fighting along the way I go in home and
told my wife this I have a new friend
who
the guy the thing the hobby Happy
Thanksgiving falls here
F that guy
can I ask was your motivation for the
Happy Thanksgiving and the come back to
this side of the street there's an
Autumn and uh look out these corn
because if I and I do it all the time I
catch myself writing let's say a firmly
worded email and for me that just means
no exclamation points and one fewer
please but I'll write this email where
I'll I'll say something like there's no
rooster in my other elements of Life
maybe that's why he comes out on stage I
should like let it out in bursts little
little slow gas leak yeah but
um if I write an email where I'm like
uh I wish I was I wasn't the only one
taking care of this can someone else do
this this or this like I feel like I'm
carrying too much of the load here yeah
I'll hit send and then I they'll reply
never to my liking nobody's ever like
hey I'm so sorry it's just always that
and then I go into super nice mode where
I'm like oh yeah well you know it just
really I was just kind of kind of
feeling things out and like are you
compensating for your like I'm gonna
call the police or what's happening no
that you changed your behavior I felt
like it was a no no what are you doing
it's not because
uh I'm just trying there's there's
different moves right there's different
moves to solve this problem wait you're
the first one was like to confront him
and be like you back the [__] off this
is uh you this is you're not gonna do
this with my wife that's not happening
you went in Denver but now we're still
like now we're still nose to nose and
it's a [__] thing you know and you
know God forbid my dog just just does
jump up and say hello and you know cuts
his arm with his her big fingernails
um you know and you can be in trouble
and whatever so I I just don't I'm not
gonna live like I said I'm carrying [__]
20 times a day on these walks I I can't
live this has to be easier yeah so let
me try this how about I don't know this
guy at all the only interaction has been
get your dog out of here
he's got knobbly he's got little bony
legs he's got funny socks who knows what
this guy is this is a weird way to walk
with your wife
what I have no idea what goes on in that
kitchen I don't know what that kitchen
looks like it's not where I live I
guarantee you it's not anything I
understand I I don't get what this is
but
why not talk to the guy for a second and
just be like look in the eyes and say
Happy Thanksgiving and see what that
does it was just another take on stay
away from my wife
yeah it wasn't motivated by guilt or
rethinking the strategy no it was just
like well rethinking the strategy yeah
yeah
but no part of you was like I should
have gone Happy Thanksgiving on the
first go
or you think they needed to be a base
coat of watch yourself yeah I don't know
this guy at all at this point this is
the first interaction right and and he's
made my way very upset
and you know I am I I am on the road and
she is alone and she's walking because
she doesn't have to deal with this guy
yeah you know who does that I would
never do that if a dog came up and I
wouldn't get in this woman's face no
when Val tells me a story and she does
every once in a while I'm driving in LA
or something and someone pulls up to her
and like rolls down the window and yells
at her hmm
it just it just drives me crazy I'm not
playing Johnny tough guy but you do yeah
who does this it's Val is the size of a
peanut and she's driving a car yeah and
she's doing her best and maybe she
accidentally cut you off or something
yeah calm the [__] down but you see how
angry I get at other people's roosters
yeah
you know what I mean some people don't
have roosters though they have alligator
monsters you know like like it makes me
grateful that I just have a rooster
yeah but your rooster is now it's not
that those are misguided roosters out in
the world like that the rooster 90 of
the time right you know what I mean yeah
yours is really backed off into a point
where it's it's very seldom will come
out and it's self-preservation well
you're making me realize that maybe it
is healthier I'm still trying to figure
this out all these years later we've
been talking about things like this on
this podcast for a long time yeah like
the appropriate use of anger or
confrontation
yeah and like some look we could sit
here and pontificate and I can act like
I'm all Zen about how I perform and then
one thing someone could say something
from the audience and all of a sudden
it comes out without your control yeah
you know what I mean well that that's
what makes rooster kind of crazy is like
this is me making an effort to not let
him out yeah
like I actually haven't completely like
blacked out like I know what's happening
and believe it or not I'm saying every
fifth thing the rooster is Whispering
for me to say you know what's so funny
as you say it though and I I hate to
keep coming back to the to the gig you
have me conscious of like the audience
not doing corporate gigs yeah but uh
your rooster on that night in Las Vegas
was lovable hilarious sweaty Pete oh man
you know what I mean like your rooster
is not like it's not like Billboard's
getting up there and then attacking the
Philadelphia Eagle fans right yeah it
was this lovable this lovable guy up
there like right just eating sugar kind
but really I mean that's like your
rooster is not a someone that's like
rolling down the window and cursing at
Val that's certainly true I maybe I
shouldn't even confuse those terms
because I like what you said those
people are roosters all the time and
then they turn into like T-Rexes yeah
and they're just nasty right and you
almost
you almost do want to catch them and be
like big man yelling it just don't don't
yell at Val as a rule if people come
close to your [__] yeah and your life
and your people you love yeah yeah this
is there's nothing wrong with that yeah
some people have to back the [__] up
they do this is a side of jump up I
didn't expect they do they Hammer a drop
well you you've got people you love yeah
and there are people out there that want
to yeah think they can cross that how
many guns do you own none
I have three bats and oh you're a bad
guy a bad guy you're a bad guy yeah yeah
you know what's so funny I would love to
have like a shotgun I always picture
myself with a shotgun like on the front
steps a double barrel yeah like oh you
want that's a single barrel yeah and
then I think maybe I just need the sound
effect maybe maybe I just need to
download off YouTube I play that on a
speaker out the window when they come I
actually
saw a thing where they can make shotguns
that don't you don't have to pump them
uh like why would you want to it seems
archaic like we've been doing that since
Western times and you know the reason
sends a message is because you want the
CH yeah you don't want them to have you
don't right it's like in in movies have
you ever noticed in a movie they point a
gun at you and it goes yeah yeah
no it doesn't
it's like the sound of the hammer
pulling back it's not it doesn't make
any sound no it's a piece of metal yeah
but it it's also somebody just recently
told me that uh Doritos for example or
Cheetos any of these O's chips
um they can make it so there's no Powder
like they can make it taste exactly the
same of course without the powder but
they're like it's the is hat licking it
off your fingers us are the [__]
animals that eat Doritos like us want to
go
like like you just got like taken into
the police station in Wisconsin are you
aware of Hanukkah Donuts hmm
my friend Avi he lives in an orthodox uh
part of LA and Katie do we know Hanukkah
and he brought me Hanukkah Donuts man
the Jewish people are so smart it's so
many things yeah and they've been trying
to they keep yelling why isn't Hanukkah
oh it's Christmas what about Hanukkah
we've got a great thing too and they're
like yeah but what do you what are you
pushing the the lighting of the yeah and
the dreidel they push the donuts you've
got these Hanukkah Donuts that only come
out in December
jelly donuts and these chocolate cream
stuffed Donuts yes what are you doing
and the everybody should know this
nobody knows Monica gelt is it called
guilt yeah the coins again not that
impressive kids love those coins yeah
you're right
you're right but the donuts if you push
the donut I didn't even know it was a
thing if you go it's a donut holiday
with gifts right also there was a
miracle with oil don't don't ask us
America loves look right the donuts are
the Santa Claus of Hanukkah agree yeah
and the cookies did I tell you this I
think you're gonna like this as a dad
yeah
why did you look at my belly when you
said that did I yeah I was trying to
look at your at your crotch Leela
um was just old enough last credit this
Christmas she's four she's gonna be like
four and a half Primo Christmas like age
she's wonderful she understands Santa
and all this stuff but the last
Christmas was the first Christmas that
we put cookies out for Santa uh and I
swear to you he is not fake I was like
we put them out for Santa and then Val
was like Leela's in bed Christmas Eve
and she's like are we you want a cookie
and I go those are for Santa and then I
go
oh my God I'm Sarah
and I ate those cookies and they were
the best cookies I've ever had in my in
my life really they were they were the
cookies of the male indoctrination
ceremony that I've been waiting for yeah
I it was the holiest communion that said
you are now a dab yeah yeah you eat
Santa's cookies you are the mouth of the
Unseen force that rewards kindness in
your children yeah and I was like Santa
is real I pee out his dick every day
what's weird about that story is that
I've never eaten the cookies and I
always wake up and they've been eating
Dia de los Muertos
[Laughter]
one of the greatest uh Santa Strokes
that I had when wait this is a what is a
Santa stroke a stroke of Genius oh
when my kids were little I had this
leather strap that had bells on it
sleigh bells on it that you put on a
door this is very good what you're
telling me and the kids were tucked into
bed
and I went outside
and just shook the thing
yes yes
and then for good measure
and then opened a bag of Doritos
and do they still talk about it
um
but what about when we heard the bells
like they they came down like we are
Bells last night
and you know who else heard Bells Tom
your neighbors and they were like
I don't remember
a grown man thought maybe Santa was real
as a guy was taking a bite of his
Hanukkah donut wait a minute maybe maybe
it is a better holiday that's fantastic
because I remember one Christmas we were
staying in someone else's house or
something and I heard Bells because I
remember even having the thought like
that doesn't seem like something my
parents would do yeah but my friend's
Burns did it and I was like yeah but I
didn't I guess I knew but I didn't know
it's probably I didn't care and I was
like still like respect yeah that's a
lot of effort yeah oh that's a good one
see the the problem with Hanukkah Donuts
is that we have Santa's cookies we have
I don't mean
my side so there still are sweets in
candy canes candy cane is a good candy
look
peppermint these Donuts are powerful
they're not going to knock down all the
stuff that Christmas has on Christmas
but it should Elevate Hanukkah in a big
way and I cannot believe how many people
are not I was not aware and as I've been
running around town saying have you
heard about the donuts a lot of people
have not can I say I haven't yeah can I
can I say there's there's a pro this is
not a problem this is a different
approach you know when you win the
lottery you win 50 million dollars do
you want it in a lump sum that's
Christmas do you want it in installments
that's Hanukkah because it's the it's
the Restraint of the seven nights it's
the it's the sting it's the way sting
brings it and but he doesn't come and
then he doesn't come it's like Sting I
don't want sting I just want to blow one
Christmas logo
I want a Sammy Hagar it I don't want a
Hagar I don't want to sting
sting is Hanukkah Sammy Hagar's
Christmas wow yeah well okay it's been a
while since you've done the podcast
there's a few questions we ask okay at
the end okay I love these do you wish I
was prepared Jesus Christ
um have you ever almost died Tom
uh
uh no
I'm going to need you to think harder
there's you've definitely almost died
well
sucked into the ocean hit by a car
pulled out to sea
uh I mean look at you you look like a
health scare
do you not go
uh that's fine I love it no yeah let's
stick with no you'll be the first and
only no I mean
there was something recently
where I told my wife
yeah it wasn't it almost died is really
on the edge
I was driving early in the morning and
um
this guy in front of me like going to
the airport to turn a rental car at like
five in the morning
one of those horrible runs and this guy
in front of me was like
swerving and stuff and he went on to the
freeway and I got onto the freeway and I
went to go around him and he did that
thing where you like come into my lane
and
they you know you realize it and go back
and he didn't go back he just hit the
side of my car oh no out of nowhere and
uh but I was I this is why whenever I
rent cars now I get the biggest thing
you could possibly give me whatever it
is really just yeah give me a tank I'm
someplace I don't know
shit's gonna go down probably so you
tell the fine people at Alamo all of
them shit's gonna go down I'm gonna give
me what you got give me what you got
gonna kill somebody
um yeah
um but that was not like the edge of
death yeah okay yeah I'm gonna say no
I'm surprised never been blackout drunk
someone pulls you out of traffic I'm
just giving you all of money yeah like
almost hit by a bus or something like
that kind of a thing yeah I guess not
uh-uh that's okay uh have you ever I'm
getting strong no vibes from you no this
next one okay but listen to the third
part okay I feel like you're gonna go no
no and then the third place I want you
to think about the third one okay okay
yes and to really give it a little gas
you disappointed me on the last question
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding I'm
100 kidding I know I'm gonna like text
you tonight and be like wait wait I was
followed by a serial killer for six
months he kept sending me cut out parts
of magazines I blacked it out one you
ever seen a ghost
two or a UFO or was not the broadness of
the third question have you ever
experienced anything that you can't
explain it could be a psychic it could
be like something that you saw something
strange just didn't make any sense and
you were anticipating what on this no no
and then I hope you could think about
the third one right
uh first one was have you seen a ghost
yeah I've seen a ghost I have a picture
of the ghost I saw
second one have I ever seen the UFO what
are you doing second one
come back uh second one UFOs was the
second one
um yeah all the time uh third one
unexplained stuff my entire life is
living in that realm my entire life is
are you translating Thoughts with with
my mother and I don't have to speak we
can communicate without it uh
yeah type things people yeah all the
time non-stop dreaming things constantly
and having them happen during the day
all the time
all the time why is that a surprise to
you because you're very
normal you're a very normal fella uh-huh
you're a suit you're a sharp suit nice
little glasses yeah reasonable that
doesn't mean that we don't live in this
mystical
magical mushroom okay is this the
picture of the ghost I'm gonna show you
the ghost is it your wallpaper it should
be
it's in my favorites it's in his
favorites okay I'm gonna look at the
picture and you tell me the tail
all right it's a great tale it's a good
tale it's an okay tail
uh I got one of those Nest cameras
and it was the first time that I had one
and I a lot of hauntings are sponsored
by nest
[Laughter]
and I was in Denver at The Comedy Works
and I'm backstage and I got the alert on
my phone we've seen activity
and I was and I I was like oh that's
cool I didn't know it did that and I put
into the link and there's my dog Bella
in my office just running around I'm
like oh that's such a cool thing that's
great you know because I had it facing
in just to see my office while I was on
the road and I said oh I said to my
opening act that would be a cool
beginning of a horror movie you get
you're out of town and you get an alert
from your nest and you turn it on and
there's just someone staring at you in
your office I'm like oh that would be
cool as I say that bling I get another
alert
as you say it as I say it and it's just
clearly a burglar and he's taking
something and that's the picture that it
took
Oh weird
no me gusta yeah it's next year Carlin
uh painting it's in your podcast Studio
isn't that your Carlin painting that you
have in your podcast that's my office
and uh it's obviously a a ghost that is
uh from like the 1940s or something he's
got a trench coat and what seems to be
like a gun and I called my wife
immediately and I'm like who's in my
office she goes it's just me and your
daughter at home there's nobody in there
there's no like Reflection from the
street it's not that kind of a place
there's no there's no
there's nothing in the camera yeah sure
go ahead
uh will you do it
oh no yeah oh no yeah I love that he's
gonna like put up your jokes there's
something a little John Mulaney about
this ghost watch it fella
you're not in here now it's my office
now pal
yeah I mean look at that that is pretty
intense it is intense and we have had
feelings in that uh house
you know Slenderman no it's got that
like no face skinny guy quality oh yeah
yeah no me gusta yeah I can't believe I
would ask this question we're talking
about comedy for an hour and a half
I know I'm sorry but okay and then you
asked what were the other ones what you
you and your mom can communicate without
words yeah we can pretty much a lot of
times especially when I was younger and
still like
still to this day like I'll think of
asking her something and then she'll
call and ask it or that kind of a thing
really yeah wow and we were when I was
younger it was
pretty it happened with frequency
for sure just predicting the future a
little bit you know just like knowing
what she was thinking or what was on her
mind and or vice versa and
articulating because while you're
sitting there thinking like should I
should I do that thing and she'll
walk in are you gonna do that thing are
you thinking about doing that thing you
know what I mean yeah a lot we were very
in tune
for almost 10 months yeah and then
uh dreams that predict the future all
the time
really small things not big things just
like like I'll wake up
all the time I'll wake up and and
um
thing why what
that's weird that the only it's weird
that I saw that red wagon I wonder if
I'm gonna see that red wagon today and
then
put down the hallway unmanned it's just
empty sorry I want to go for a wagon
ride before I Rob someone in your office
but it's always odd things like that
you're not even and a lot of times
you're not even thinking like am I going
to see that it's just there was just
um you know someone walking with a a
green shopping bag or something and
you're just going about your day like oh
there it goes you like that kind of
thing whoa yeah spicy chicken spicy
chicken what do you do you have any
makeup what what that means
you have The Shining no I don't know
what it is I think it's just uh
I don't know I don't know how this place
works but I do know that uh
I do know that
there's parts of it that are unseen that
um that stuff's going on and it kind of
creeps through it creeps through the
fabric sometimes well you know it's
interesting if you talk to a lot of
spiritual folks like myself and you push
them to the limits meaning take keep
going steps back steps back
um you'll get to usually a lot of people
have a a idea that God is or everything
is one thing yeah
um and that time is an illusion or time
is how uh these seemingly separate
vessels experience eternity you know
like in these bite-sized beds but like
and even quantum physics would say that
time might be an illusion and that
everything seems to be happening at once
and it's being experienced in these
different things
um
so if that's true then there's no reason
why someone who is tuning into the
allness of everything could experience a
past life or could see the future or
could see the near future yeah and now I
feel like it's a comedy movie and I'm
like you've just been given this gift in
a completely worthless way
you can't help us
help you yeah yeah it's not not really
doing much for you green grocery bags I
don't know where it's supposed to go or
where am I supposed to use it pitch this
next special oh my God that would be be
useful there is a uh I think that it
does play into
um
a comfort and a patience with the world
I think that it has a a kind of EX
um
there's an expectation or a lack of
expectation of what's going on that uh
opens that up yeah for sure well for
sure I think that um so my rooster is
[__] blocking my psychic abilities
yeah yeah
yeah
for sure I believe it yeah interesting
you know so there are times in your life
where it's higher more relaxed if you're
more relaxed as a tune in more during
the pandemic did you have it more uh I
think that
yeah it's hard yeah I think when you're
I don't know I've been doing TM for like
I don't know six years or eight eight
years or something like that and that's
kind of this is what I've been thinking
about recently
like as we're all trying to figure out
all this stuff and like all the stuff
you were listing and
and like what what where are we playing
like what is this thing that we're
playing and and like why is everybody
searching for these religions and these
answers are just weird just spirituality
like why do we always have this like
little yeah
when you think about how intensely
complicated and Powerful
a human brain is
the human brain is
we don't even unders our human brains
can't figure out our human brains
they're so in tune and we're only using
a certain portion of it and it's like I
started thinking we're kind of we're
carrying these incredibly intense
antenna in our beings that is aware
of something else we're all and it ends
up chasing religion and chasing all
we're all sensing it but we don't have
the capability to even
decipher the information that's coming
through it yeah it's amazing it's like
like we're we're there we've got it
we're feeling it we're sensing it but we
don't have a real handle on it I would
add you are it you it's just completely
impossible to really clear out all the
static and and even if you could clear
out the static and observe pure mind
like capital M mind or her Consciousness
or awareness language and faculty would
completely fail you you wouldn't be able
to come back and describe it yeah you
know what I'm saying it's funny that you
said antenna because I would think your
brain my my metaphysical worldview is
more like your brain is more of a
instrument that's funneling mind that's
funneling the quality of
think not not just thinking but being
itself and what I'm saying is I started
still receiving
yeah it's it's the the part of the human
I mean the way that we can study it and
all that stuff we're seeing it but like
if we look in your brain we can't really
find you right you know there's no
consciousness Globe I tried in the van
from the airport the other last night I
was like I had to park an economy
parking or taking a van meaning it was
full and it's just this off-site parking
so I'm in this off-site parking van and
I said to this woman
the driver was like do you guys remember
where you parked it's been a few days
and I was like yeah I do and the woman
was like I do too and I go isn't that
weird where is that memory like what did
we just do yeah yeah like where did we
go and you know there's no physical
right it's not like it's written down
and even if it were just written or a
little slide or a little movie file
who's finding it you know what I mean
like all that stuff is such a mystery so
I said to the owner I was like isn't it
weird like how did we find that memory
where is that memory and she just was
like yeah she's like I'm just finding my
car pal no nobody nobody wants to talk
about this stuff but I think whether or
not that's literally true I think I'm
agreeing with you that there's more
going on than we understand yeah and I
think I think at the end accepting that
no one really has a handle on it even
the greatest philosophers and religious
figures and thinkers
I think it's I think uh the reason why I
I am
comfortable and aware and maybe dream
that stuff and whatever is um knowing
that there's not really an answer and
it's it but it's a pretty cool thing
just to know that we're just observers
yeah like just like what you did in that
van is like that was pretty cool that's
pretty detached and out of yourself and
in yourself and you kind of like
it's all happening I don't have to find
the answers but I think it's maybe it's
enough just to be a cool Observer of it
all yeah right and you get these little
Winks yeah like you get wings right
right from the universe yeah and then
you can we say this on the show all the
time but then you can become the wink
like then you telling these stories
maybe or the wing to the people
listening to yeah and it's as little
reminder I tend to like dream language
some people get freaked out by it but
I'm like we're having a strange dream
yeah and like don't forget that we're
having strange dreams yeah I mean we
don't have time to get it we do but yeah
I'm not gonna get all into it it's like
I I will quote one thing it's like the
idea that everything is made of
Consciousness isn't actually that hard
of a stretch meaning there's nothing to
seeing except sight or there's nothing
to what you perceive except seeing and
there's nothing to seeing except knowing
meaning it's a phenomenon that happens
in your Consciousness or touching is
feeling and feeling happens and meaning
everything is built and put together in
this thing that we don't know it's very
matrix it's like these are electrical
signals interpreted by your brain so
yeah when you say reality is a dream
you're really saying reality is made of
mind or reality is made of Consciousness
we have an opposite view in the west
which is that we are conscious and we
perceive a world that is here
um but really there's not
you I know the dream is studying the
dream yeah does that make sense yeah so
you studied the Dream from within the
dream and you go like this isn't a dream
but you're using your dream to be like
this isn't a dream I know there's no way
to get outside of the dream right
exactly I mean just is there
Consciousness is that a thing I mean
okay go down that Wormhole for the rest
of your life yeah and you're not gonna
really come out with an answer no one
has
um maybe all the discussion is pushing
us towards a place or a time where
someone will crack it or we will will
evolve into a a state where we can but
it's not going to happen
these next 50 years so I think it's just
a cool thing to be to not fight it and
just be aware of
of it you know
that's just where I'm at right well
that's that's my daughter's name the the
dance Leela means the dance of the
universe yeah you can just You Can Dance
the dance yeah yeah and not worry too
much yeah that's my favorite question if
you ask an Eckhart Tolle or a Rupert
Spire or whoever these people that I
like you go is there anything to worry
about they would all say no right
exactly but there's a great comfort in
that yeah until someone
rolls the window down and yells at your
wife and then you're like right but
instinct to saying I want to preserve
this life that I have right here right
yeah that's true well nothing can attack
you it's not what happens to you it's
your thoughts about what happens to you
that are attacking you right you know
what I mean even if I'm telling you
you're not [__] it's like yeah but Pete
Pete might just be mad at himself or you
don't you don't know unless you
interpret it in a certain way and we're
back to the guy walking in front of his
wife walking the dog right like I am
being attacked right and then that'll
either be uh confirmed by reality but
what's interesting about spirituality is
it's reminding you that you have this
other choice right there's another way
to interpret what's happening yeah yeah
and have fewer thoughts fewer
expectations and and therefore fewer
interpretations of what's happening I
mean you can see things more clearly
we're back to the rooster I'm
interpreting what should be happening
and which what is happening and I'm
wrong on every count yeah and and when I
watch Eckhart when I saw him in La
recently terrible venue terrible sound
everything from where I was sitting yeah
I was roostering on his behalf I was
like this sucks he seemed totally fine
yeah he was like great beyond totally
fine he had one of those Madonna mics
that kept breaking and he was just like
I'll wait for a new microphone I was
like oh I see all right I get it I can't
I can't do it but I I see there's a
human potential to being late and you
know what he was asking in the middle
when it wasn't working but in this quiet
little way what's that what's happening
right now what's happening right now
what's happening yeah this isn't how it
went the other night in fact that's one
of my favorite practices of his it's
also in A Course in Miracles but it's
like you look at things and you drop the
label like if you could stop telling
this thing it's a couch yeah and looking
at it instead of telling it what it is
asking it what it is I I'll say from
experience you can trip balls that way
yeah in fact I would say that's what
psychedelics are doing is it's taking
you from a place of telling real idea
what it is to asking it what it is and
when you ask it what it is it'll show
you what it is and it's not what you
think it is let's do some coke
wow the last five minutes of the podcast
we're very intense yeah I do have a I do
have a we have time to go into it but I
uh
there is a
I'm a little suspicious of the
psychedelics are showing us the way
sure because you're also on drugs you're
also putting your brain into a state
that is you're you're igniting parts of
it that is creating that feeling true
you know what I mean like it's
interesting when you consider that
science says that this is a
hallucination this is just a
hallucination that we agree upon yeah
you know what I'm saying so psychedelics
make you have a different hallucination
right but I would I would say the lesson
is in the constant between those two
states is still Consciousness whether or
not you're perceiving me sitting on this
couch or me with a bobble clown head
with a spring neck and I'm vomiting Tic
Tac yeah like it's still the one thing
that carried over between those two
experiences that is in your dreaming
State and your waking State and was with
you when you were a child and is with
you now and is actually the same as when
you were a child and it's the same now
that is the only thing that should be
interesting and Rupert Spire actually
addresses that he's like awareness or
Consciousness he likes awareness is
there whether and he uses the word
hallucinating he's there it's there when
you're dreaming it's there when you're a
child right there when you're working
it's there when you're playing it's when
you're happy when you're sad when you're
depressed when you're sick when you're
this and he goes and when you're
hallucinating it doesn't matter I'm with
you yeah the problem I have with it is
when people all of a sudden maybe
because they're closed off in other
parts of their life when they take
hallucinogenics and then they think oh
now I'm now I'm aware right well you
could have been aware before you took it
completely agree you know what I mean I
don't see that as the thing that is
unlocking this other realm at a certain
point well
um trunk parimbache called it um
a delusion inside of a delusion
yeah and I I my life has been greatly
served by psychedelics but I've also
seen it I can't speak to other people
but I've seen a lot of people being like
I'm going to ring the bell for the 300th
time and you're like at a certain point
right is it a tool or is it is it what
is it I can't yeah I mean it's cool it's
fun it's a great blessing it's all that
it's yeah but it doesn't yeah but I
don't see that I don't see that that is
the I think you could live a life
without it and know that what you saw
through the haze of mushrooms was there
I just told yes I just told you that if
you so the prompting of Course in
Miracles as you look at this cushion you
say I above all else I want to see this
cushion differently yeah and if you just
take 10 minutes and really slow your
breath down and be calm and look at your
hand or look at a tree and say above all
else I want to see this tree differently
you'll know what it feels like to take
mushrooms the great thing about
mushrooms is right you don't have to
have any discipline right I mean I'm but
I'm telling you that it takes 10 minutes
of mild discipline and I would say a
belief that it's going to work you have
to kind of like go into it being like
this is this is happening right I I
don't mean I'm gonna trip but like
you're you're committed yeah you you do
it and you do it with yeah with uh
meaning right right then you then you'll
because I I've done mushrooms and I've
done that exercise and both have the
same sort of weird like what is
happening yeah yeah yeah really yeah
yeah if mushrooms were the only answer I
mean right right yeah no 100 yeah when
we really know that the the real answer
is Hanukkah Donuts
CDs or hd's depending on how you spell
it this is this is you guys like CDs I'm
sorry do you like high def or compact
discs the last and final question Tom we
went everywhere yes we did it all
right last time we did the podcast we
weren't asking this question pretty sure
I'm not sure
can you tell me the time in your life
you laughed the hardest in your life
or barring that
where are you like any great one your
young tears are streaming yeah you're
like somebody fell somebody farted yeah
I'm with you I got a recent one and I'll
do it um it's when my kids said that um
I got the new phone it's so big again oh
my God so big too big
um this is what my kids say I've never
saw my father laugh Harder Than This
Moment
uh and they say it all the time and
they're right it was I think it's
probably
I've never had a we've never had a third
person account like someone else yeah
said that oh no this is when you and I
was I was really just out of control and
it's so stupid it's so great I can't
wait then I found I discovered uh the
fart app on your phone and we were with
my parents at their house and I found
the fart app on my phone and I'm just
playing all the different farts there's
like the nuclear fart and the are they
real first and the wet fart and the I
don't know if they're you'd know you'd
know you're familiar they seem synthetic
okay but still very effective people
actually prefer the synthetic yeah
they're powerful yeah nobody wants some
guy just doing it
it wouldn't take years it would take
years to get all the different varietals
I'm playing the fart noises
and it's making my mother angry
Tom will you stop that
Tom I'm serious will you ask
Tom we and it's
and uh and it's making her angrier and
angrier and every time I let and then so
it'll be quiet and then
like
and I just like a child with my mom all
over again was crying laughing just
tears turning purple at this dumb
activity of just hitting more fart
noises that was making my mother just
pull her hair I am not kidding it is
will you stop that someone get his phone
all right I won't do it
I just tears and my daughter's to this
day are like we never saw you left in
your life because a lot of our answers
to this question is church laughter it
has to be a situation where you're not
supposed to live right right and that's
where the religious have an advantage
they have a leg up in this question but
you had your mother yeah the voice of
your superego grow up yeah but yeah and
quite frankly you should know how this
makes me feel because we're psychically
bonded right exactly
Tommy pops you're the best thanks for
coming on you have a book it's coming
out in January though or something like
that no I have my Netflix special coming
up no no
JK
December 13th oh I didn't know okay a
week from today okay
right or is what's today
so it might
it'll be out when people hear this it'll
be out it'll be out it's called what a
day it just came out on Netflix what a
day I like I it's I don't say that in
the ACT I just uh I say that in my life
whenever I come in the kitchen in the
morning with my family I'm like what a
day what a day and then at the end and I
like it because by the by five o'clock
it's what a day yes what a day I can't
believe you didn't you just did the bit
yeah you know it's not in my act at all
you're doing great is you're doing great
yeah you're doing great yeah yeah well
congrats man I'm excited to see it yeah
check it out and um yeah my book doesn't
come out till June actually all right so
we won't even talk about it we'll talk
again all right uh would you say keep it
crispy it's how we end you say keep it
crispy keep it crispy
[Laughter]
believe me
[Music]